consider looking at yourself in the
mirror have you ever looked so closely
and intensely at your reflection that
you start to become aware of the details
and complexities of your skin that you
otherwise never notice have you ever
stared at your reflection until you no
longer recognize it what is it that you
are looking at is it you are you your
face are you your brain do you control
entirely what it is that you are looking
at if it decides to grow hair do you
have any say in the matter
you can cut or shave the hair but it
will still continue to grow what you are
staring at is therefore not entirely
yours it belongs partly to the
collective entity of life what you are
staring at is part stranger to you and
you must make friends with it or it will
become your worst enemy as humans we are
just as unconscious as we are conscious
for everything that we can control and
understand about ourselves there is an
equal amount that we cannot we sit
somewhere in the middle between complete
consciousness and complete
unconsciousness and this is arguably
where all human conflict stems from
smart enough to understand the notion of
complete control and perfection but not
smart enough to achieve it we have yet
to become what we conceive and expect of
ourselves but no matter how hard we try
at this point in evolution
we will never be of complete and perfect
omniscience we all know this yet it
still seems that we constantly expect
perfection from ourselves and the rest
of the world
but we must not depend our purpose and
excitement in life on whether or not we
can control and perfect everything our
sense of purpose and excitement is found
in the way that our imperfection keeps
life fresh uncertain and inspiring only
those who can possess the conscious
abilities of the human but not be
tormented by the conscious in abilities
of the human will become into what it
truly means to be human in the first
place we must learn how to separate the
desire of perfection and the expectation
of perfection it is admirable and very
human to strive for perfection but it is
equally human to not achieve it we must
remember this as we travel through life
so that we do not become disheartened
and void of wonder and enjoyment
[Music]
you
you